[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
emergencia que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 nos adaptamos
desde nuestros hogares para llevarles
toda la información
-soy valentina torres sánchez gracias
por acompañarme iniciamos hablando de
cómo varios países de áfrica donde el
acceso médico es restringido han
implementado importantes iniciativas
tecnológicas en medio de la crisis
causada por el contagio de kobe en abuya
la capital de nigeria la firma y health
áfrica se ha encargado de hacer posible
que las consultas se realicen a través
de una videollamada por su parte la
compañía ágil human health que se
especializa en digitalizar expedientes
médicos lanzó su plataforma de consulta
para ofrecer datos claros sobre los
contagios en nigeria ambas firmas han
explicado que es necesario mejorar la
calidad de las comunicaciones y del
internet en amplios sectores del
continente
de lo contrario el acceso a la salud
cada vez será más complejo
y la gente no estaba emocionada ni
prestando atención pero afortunadamente
la gente ha visto especialmente en
nuestra comunidad y en nigeria lo
inadecuado del sistema de salud y la
única forma de enfrentar o contenido el
virus es mediante soluciones
tecnológicas que nos ayudarán a manejar
la respuesta
y continuamos hablando de ccoo y 19 pero
esta vez del distanciamiento social en
reinounido de la empresa azar sus una
fabricante de robots creó un dispositivo
personal que le avisa a sus 400
empleados si están demasiado cerca se
llamaba amp y utiliza tecnología
bluetooth de baja energía y radio de
banda ultraancha para obtener datos de
ubicación precisos así las personas
saben qué tan cerca están de otros
dispositivos si un empleado se desplaza
a menos de dos metros bomb emite una luz
azul y un solo pitido si dos personas
están a menos de un metro parpadea en
rojo y emite un pitido continuo
que está ayudando a las personas a hacer
algo que no es intuitivo todos olvidamos
la distancia a pesar de la cinta en los
pisos y cosas por el estilo antes de
tener agua todavía estábamos invadiendo
el espacio seguro de las personas
entonces ven sólo te da ese empujón para
decir ten cuidado da un paso atrás sin
ser incómodo sin que una persona sienta
que está invadiendo a otra
vamos ahora hasta rusia puntualmente a
san petersburgo el uso de los tapabocas
cada vez es más aceptado en muchos
lugares del mundo sin embargo estos
elementos pueden llegar a ser una
barrera para las personas que sufren de
discapacidad auditiva es por ello que
allí una empresa fabrica mascarillas
especiales cuentan con una pantalla de
plástico en el centro que permite ver
los labios de la persona que la porta
cuando comenzó la pandemia las personas
con discapacidad auditiva quedaron
excluidas del mundo exterior hay una
cantidad muy pequeña de personas 100%
sordas para té y prosperidad y muchos
usan audífonos y para comprender el aula
se basan en la percepción sonora y
visual leyendo el sonido porque cada
sonido tiene articulación visual
y es muy importante que una persona que
habla tenga la cara descubierta pero
cuando todos empezaron a usar máscaras
los niños en la escuela no podían ver a
sus maestros en las tiendas la gente de
los hospitales comenzó a enfrentar la
realidad de no poder recibir información
además de diseñar este tapabocas los
responsables de la iniciativa se
ocuparon de que la pantalla plástica no
se empañe para ello aplican jabón
líquido que crea una película protectora
y permite que no haya condensación
durante aproximadamente una hora
cambiamos de tema y llegamos a países
bajos allí investigadores de la
universidad tecnológica de delft crearon
lo que llaman un ataúd viviente está
hecho principalmente de hongos y busca
que el proceso de descomposición de los
cuerpos se haga sin contaminar los
suelos que luego podrán ser usados como
terrenos fértiles esta es la forma más
natural de ser enterrado así ya no
contaminamos el medio ambiente con las
toxinas de nuestro cuerpo y todo lo que
va a los ataúdes sino que en realidad
tratamos de enriquecerlo y ser realmente
abono para la naturaleza
el ataúd está hecho principalmente con
micelio una parte de los hongos que
combinada con otros microorganismos
permite acelerar el proceso de
descomposición y neutraliza toxinas los
responsables de este invento aseguran
que un cuerpo puede tardar una década en
descomponerse y las partes barnizadas y
metálicas de cualquier ataúd además de
la ropa sintética se demoran aún más
mientras que con este producto el
proceso puede completarse en dos o tres
años
en realidad es un organismo está hecho
de micelio que es la estructura de la
raíz de los hongos y es el mayor
reciclador de la naturaleza por lo que
pueden descomponer nuestro cuerpo en
nuevos nutrientes para que la naturaleza
florezca finalizamos este espacio en
seúl la capital surcoreana donde cada
vez hay más robots meseros en medio de
la pandemia de kobe 19 pues hoy veremos
un aparato que es el camarero estrella
de un restaurante de hamburguesas es
capaz de tomar el pedido comunicarlo a
la cocina y transportarlo hasta el
cliente esto permite que no haya ninguna
interacción cara a cara con personal del
lugar
una vez que la máquina pasa los
ingredientes cocidos nuestro personal
los combina con aderezos en una
hamburguesa o durante siga la envuelve y
se la entrega a un robot de servicio el
cliente puede tomar la comida sin ningún
contacto directo con el personal o
cadetes o al combinar el mapeo espacial
3d y la conducción autónoma el robot
puede moverse libremente a través de
pasos estrechos entre mesas y evitar
obstáculos para llegar a su destino se
pueden servir los pedidos de hasta
cuatro mesas a la vez
así concluimos esta crónica cuídense si
es posible permanezcan en casa recuerden
que la salud es lo primero gracias por
su compañía y continúen con más en
france24 france24 puntocom
sí